once again good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen we have had very detailed and
substantive talks on the whole range of
issues which have to do with our
relations and we discussed the situation
around Venezuela today Venezuela is our
long-standing partner they we reaffirm
our solidarity with the people and the
legitimate government of Venezuela in
its efforts to defend its independence
and sovereignty we believe that we need
to fully comply the fundamental
principles of the United Nations Charter
and I mean every country among these
principles is of course the principle of
non interventions in the affairs of
other countries this is especially
important to remember about that today
when we see such a cynical campaign
aimed at toppling the legitimate
government of Venezuela through threats
of use of force direct intervention
Russia has been consistent in supporting
the peaceful resolution of the crisis
inside Venezuela it is clear that the
attempts to better situation should be
made by the people of Venezuela
themselves by Venezuela without any
imposition of will from abroad without
any ultimatums we express our solidarity
with the friendly people of Venezuela we
support the efforts exercised by medoras
government to prevent d--ation from
further destabilization and we reaffirm
our commitment to join those efforts
regional efforts international efforts
aimed at mediating the conflict and
finding a way to start an inclusive
national dialogue we are ready to
participate in such activities if
Venezuela
if key political forces inside Venezuela
agreed to that
why's President Rodriguez said many
times after president Maduro that the
leadership of Venezuela is ready to have
that kind of dialogue so in that context
it is very regretful that the opposition
has been consistent in refusing to have
that dialogue following direct orders
from Washington mr. Rodriguez briefed me
on the current developments inside
Venezuela it told about the work which
is being done to stabilize the economic
situation social situation because its
deterioration as we know was caused by
the introduction by the United States of
the illegitimate unilateral sanctions
against the key sectors of Venezuelans
economy and blockade freezing of
Venezuela's assets and Great Britain in
the UK and in the United States this
issue of Unitarian age should not be
politicized we need to solve this
problem through the established
international procedures not manipulate
the public opinion not mobilize the
anti-government of voice inside the
country and there should be no excuse
for justifying interventionism miss
Rodriguez reaffirmed the commitment of
the Venezuelan government to cooperate
on the issues of communitarian hate help
with designated United Nations bodies
Russia will continue to help the news
well and authorities in solving social
economic problems by supplying
humanitarian aid and support we believe
that's the best way to support Venezuela
is to have a broad dialogue and
cooperation of everyone we need to take
steps which are necessary to reinforce
our ties in such sectors as investments
and finance in compliance with the
arrangements that the two presidents
reached in December we also discussed
the preparatory work for the 14th
meeting of the high-level
Intergovernmental Commission which is
planned to take place
in early April this year in Moscow and
we agreed to use this platform as a good
opportunity for us to discuss the
further prospects for implementing major
projects in surveying and exploration
works joint projects in such sectors as
peaceful items military-technical
cooperation high technologies we agreed
to continue our close cooperation and
dialogue and we reaffirm our commitment
to coordinate our actions closely in the
United Nations and its Security Council
and other international organizations
thank you
talking to the media here I would like
to say I would like to express our
gratitude to President Putin and mr.
Lavrov and all Russian people for the
support support of the people of
Venezuela and the constitutionally
elected government our president Nicolas
Maduro we know that there are a number
of maneuvers aimed at worsening the
situation in Venezuela and these
attempts mostly from the United States
want to change the regime that they
don't like legitimate government and the
constitutional Institute's of Venezuela
we have an interesting program for
Russia our president instructed us to
deepen our strategic partnership with
Russia in December last year president
Maduro visited Russia that was an
official visit and he signed new
agreements and we're getting ready to
expand our cooperation and new
agreements
two hundred and sixty-four agreements
that we have already signed in April
they will be a new conference between
intergovernmental commissions and new
agreements will be signed
we're here to underline to underscore
that Venezuela is looking for new ways
in this new geopolitical situation we
support the countries who defend
international law and we welcome and
inform the creation of the informal
group in the UN to put to defend the UN
Charter and international law more
people support us more people of the
world it's the countries who support the
multipolar World Order and oppose the
one polar world water and sanctions that
one that want to destroy our economy but
they will not be successful
unfortunately the West is excluding
itself from the global arena because
they're now trying to undermine the
international community and several
countries countries that respect
international law now strengthen
bilateral relations and I would like to
say that president Maduro instructed us
instructed Elizabeth Lisbon Office of
our oil company to close the office
there in Lisbon and move it to Moscow
you know what's happening with oil
assets in the USA and other countries
that are not friendly with Venezuela our
assets are being frozen like in the UK
for example that used the Bank of
England and basically stole our gold and
we will defend our rights
through courts and and and bring back
our assets we are thankful grateful for
the friendship that we see and I would
also like to confirm with mr. Lavrov and
I discussed in person we need some
mechanisms some permanent mechanisms for
our dialogue we are for the dialogue we
are ready to work and talk with the
opposition in Venezuela we support the
initiatives proposed by Mexico and
Uruguay Venezuela does not want military
intervention our continent does not want
military intervention from the US or any
other country we want peace stable
stability and we are convinced that we
can only achieve our goals through
peaceful dialogue as far as humanity the
humanitarian aid issue this has been
happening since 2015 the head of
Pentagon John Kelly back then said said
that if there is a humanitarian crisis
in the country then the United States is
going to intervene but they kind of
jumped the gun on this one the
government of Venezuela is working with
international agencies including your
different UN agencies making sure that
we receive humanitarian aid through the
UN or other friendly countries like
Russia for example but we would not
allow a unit unilateral illegal
humanitarian aid that has its goal to
destroy Venezuela that is our agenda and
we will continue to strengthen our
relations with Russia and our stance on
the global arena will expand our trade
opportunities and president Maduro gave
specific instructions
and we know what our people need like
medications and other things we will buy
them from Russia and we will manufacture
everything we can in our country with
the help of Russia and that's good news
for the world for them Venezuela for
Russia
we are strategic partners and we work
for the good of our people hello vice
president vice president Rodriguez the
first question we would like to know
what measures can the Supreme Court of
Venezuela use if guardo comes back to
Venezuela and also what do you and
Minister Lavrov think about the plan the
United States plan to create illegal
military units and make the situation
similar to what's happening in Syria
thank you I would like the whole world
to hear that mr. Guido MP who was
elected by 7,000 votes and he was second
that's 97 thousand votes and he was not
the most popular MP and he was not he
did not hold the prominent position on
the national level either but he
proclaimed himself president because he
has the support of the United States and
other countries who that do not like the
Venezuela it's just it's all part of
big plan to damage our country it's
crime against our constitutional order
and this person is working with an
international government to undermine
the lawful the legitimate government of
Venezuela Venezuela has all necessary
mechanisms to protect its institutions
its constitution if as far as the u.s.
plans go mr. Lavrov and I have already
discussed this information and we
exchanged important data important
information it's not something new you
know that they've already used this
mechanism in Syria and other countries
as far as operation against Venezuela a
very experienced person is heading up
that operation mr. Abrams
he has already been involved in this
kind of activities and there are certain
plans and certain steps aimed at
establishing some illegal military units
that is the the u.s. always does
basically they create terrorist groups
and if the whole world knows that they
do that that they have this practice and
it's not it's no secret in the United
States supports these extremist groups
these illegal terrorist organizations
and uses them to destabilize peace but
it will not happen in Venezuela and I
will explain why our independence is
basically the connection between the
army and the people in our people and
our army are together are united they
will protect in defense the territorial
integrity and independence of our
country as from the plans of the
statistical association with the help of
local military groups
well these plans certainly a very
alarming - yes openly talks about this
the information we have shows that
in the upcoming future the United States
is planning to buy in one of the Eastern
European countries light arms weapons
motors anti-aircraft portable weapons
and then send it closer to Venezuela
with the help of E air cargo company
which is absolutely loyal to the regime
friendly with Washington we know about
these plans and many other countries
know about them to neighbours Venezuela
are aware of that and as well as
neighbors Colombian Brazil said that
they would not be supporting in any way
plans like that it would not support any
military intervention in Venezuela so if
they hold their promises if they stand
strong then I think that these plans of
United States would not come true the
world is all Maori solutions I hope that
will cool down their hard hats in
Washington but there are some people who
will never stop there we will continue
working on the basis of the
international law and will continue to
demand from the other states full
compliance with the international law I
have two questions my first question is
from mr. Lavrov do we deliver any
humanitarian aid to Venezuela and so do
we continue do we plan to continue to do
so and my second question is for vice
president Rodriguez Venezuela says that
there's no humanitarian crisis in the
country does it mean that Venezuela does
not need any help including help from
Russia
I will start since the clinic question
was addressed to me I said already in my
Philemon remarks that we discussed today
Unitarian issues these military entices
which is artificially being turned into
something else for the help of sanctions
intellectual sanctions free grazing the
assets of Venezuela abroad this crisis
certainly takes its toll on the
situation the government of Venezuela
does always can to solve the current
issues under the guidance of the
relevant UN bodies this is happening
fully within the framework of the law
these efforts fully complied with
international from Darren laws and the
rules existent within the family of the
United Nations for such situations and
that's relation I would like to say that
special and were the United States on
Venezuela on this crisis mr. Elliott
Abrams said that the United States will
not be cooperating with any UN agencies
and this will not be helping them to
transport military in aid because these
agencies of the United Nations that's
what he said cooperate with the
government of Medora that's the u.s.
position the position of a country which
says it cares so much about the people
of Venezuela which creates provocation
setups on its border that happened
already and all of us wants is to
destabilize the situation topple down
the missouri regime as for Russia's
position on this according to the
requests from Venezuela we sent the
first batch of madsen and drugs 7.5 tons
that was done the expense of our
contributions regular contributions to
the international organization just with
the help of the Panamera
Okin health organization we received an
expanded list of the Matteson that
venezuela needs we will be assessing it
most carefully finding best ways to
supply what is needed thinking about
this crisis but the humanitarian
situation in Venezuela in general I
think that deliveries agricultural
products is what helping a lot to solve
the situation namely wheat thank you
very much for this question because it
allows us to see how we were building
this inclusive model of social justice
in Venezuela you know that there's very
little inequality in Venezuela the Lima
group countries if we take them they
have horrible social and economic
situation there the poverty in Colombia
is horrible
there are serious social problems in
those countries but that's not because
of the humanitarian crisis but it's
because of the neoliberal model that the
Lima countries in Colombia chose and now
they're talking about Venezuela in
Venice vessels humanitarian crisis
they're doing that to justify the
military intervention they want a
pretext for this military intervention
the situation in Venezuela let's compare
it to Honduras or Paraguay for example
what's happening in those countries is
horrible compared to Venezuela the Human
Development Index is very high in
Venezuela Venezuela just needs
this illegal economic blockade to stop
because it because of this blockade we
cannot bring in food and medications
into the countries and we cannot
manufacture them and that is the reason
for the humanitarian crisis they was
artificially engineered by the United
States this crisis they are stealing our
assets literally stealing our financial
assets it is basically an armed robbery
what's happening we are just they are
stealing our resources our finances and
we've already said that Venezuela you
can get can finance the medications and
the food we spoke with the European
Union and we gave the list of the food
that we can pay for but we want to get
that food and medications first now
there is a sea blockade and all this
Elisa's cannot be brought to Venezuela
they're so intolerant that they're
engineering this crisis this is what our
president is saying they're choking you
but they want you to respond the first
condition is for them to stop choking
choking us so we're calling
international community to stop this
illegal blockade or of our country and
that will help Venezuela and also our
assets that have been frozen in European
banks that can be used to buy food and
medications and that can be done through
international agencies the UN agencies
which is a real cooperation mechanisms
not some pseudo humanitarian aid we know
what happened just recently that was
fake humanitarian aid
it included materials for
escalating violence in Venezuela that
was not the real humanitarian aid we've
seen this before there have been cases
when as that weapons were delivered to
Venezuela's humanitarian aid and my
distinguished colleague has already
mentioned that these are these weapons
were were sent to armed some illegal
groups militant groups in Venezuela and
now Colombia is letting use its
territory to organize these attacks on
Venezuela and that's the Dare thanks for
our help in the peace process this peace
process was not finished and now they're
paying us back by allowing this
aggression to be planned on its
territory so this is what we need we
need this blockade to end but I'm afraid
that it won't happen because now
sanctions have become the business model
so you just push a button and you take
away someone's resources we're in the
digital era now the neo imperialist
neo-colonial era and you can basically
steal resources of whole nations with
just one click
hello Sinan mr. Lavrov do you think the
direct military intervention US
intervention is possible because
President Trump has already said that
and it has been reiterated that all
options are on the table
why is your government miss vice prez
your government against the new election
in Venezuela yes I said already that
there is not a single country and there
also use except for probably one or two
closest allies
dates who would support for young would
accept military interventions in
Venezuela everyone including in as well
as neighbors have already voiced their
determination not to accept that not to
support this I know the ways of the
current US administration and this is
why I can say that yes everything is
possible I cannot rule out that the US
administration can really something that
would again violate every international
law in principles and Elliott Abrams who
was appointed especially yes and Roy for
Venezuela makes no secret of his
functions including any peace solution
no the only thing he does is to spur up
tensions creating the situation which
would provoke march to the like in the
US an explosion inside Venezuela
bloodshed inside Venezuela and that
would be justifying the US intervention
no one makes any secret of that in
Washington I cannot rule out that these
statements would again be just a
stepping stone for such things
outrages adventures and the situation if
Washington goes in circumvention of the
positions of the countries of this
region and tries to invade Venezuela is
that would just show immediately the
motives behind the u.s. policies in
Latin America these policies have
nothing to do with democracy even though
she says it's all about democracy
the only thing videos does here is
imposing it's world making everyone bow
to its will
said already that it's not about
Venezuela it's about Cuba and Nicaragua
- next day yes my dislike someone else
it may say that elections of these of
that country or not democratic and it
will all happen again again I don't
think that this kind of as it here and
they said it huge it's outrageous it
will not help Washington score any
points in Latin America those that an
Americans we have deep traditions of
democracy traditions of cooperation
gather with other countries as part of
the original in ization z-- they would
say what they have in mind right away
just as the rest of the international
community if it that happens I hope that
common sense would prevail among the US
establishment before I answer your
question
I would like the CNN journalists will
you broadcast my full answer will the
CNN show my answer you said that we're
against the election but we defend our
Constitution the election already took
place in due time in 2018 and present
Maduro won that election and he's gonna
be in office until 2025 we've had 25
elections in the last 20 years and
Chavez
Travis's ideology has lost only twice
during those elections the united states
they like to talk about elections but
even in the u.s. it's not the majority
of votes that decide who's going to be
president in Venezuela we can't all the
boats and people supported president
Maduro so we are defending our country
and nobody can demand that we break the
constitution of our country so we are
defending protecting our Constitution
thank you hello my first question is for
mr. Lavrov Russian resolution and the
Security Council had fewer votes and if
not the veto of China Andhra and Russia
the u.s. resolution would have been
passed and for the first time in history
the Security Council would vote to
change the regime in Venezuela so in
this situation are there any ways for
Venezuela to decide its own future and
my question is for vice president
Rodriguez as well there is a debate in
the UN on the candidacy of Godot because
the u.s. threatened Venezuela if go I
dough was detained is there any way to
stop this intervention we're looking
right now we're seeing that other
countries are imposing their will on
Venezuela I would also like to to ask
you to talk more about the relocation of
the oil company office why are you doing
that
as for the yesterday's vote in the UN
Security Council
let's not cows voices in favor of this
of that resolution the main thing is
that neither of the two resolutions were
adopted doesn't mean that one project
was more legitimate and the other one
was less legitimate the UN chart says
full procedure for making decisions
which would be obligatory for the
international community and that
procedure means a resolution can be
passed only if there is no veto if the
veto right is exercised then that
resolution cannot be legitimate cannot
be presented as something more positive
than some other draft resolution these
are the rules and these are the rules in
which the international law is based on
the United Nations is founded on these
rules like to remind you of that when
the UN was created it was the United
States suggested and insisted that the
Security Council members permit Security
Council members had that veto right the
founding fathers of the United Nations
believe that positions position of one
country permanent representative of the
Security Council should not be ignored
because there is too much experience
Malpass than minimize when decisions are
taking in the wrong way the consequences
cannot be good options on the table and
whether it's possible to make it so that
Venezuela would decide its own future
today we talked about the Montevideo
mechanism was created thanks to
Mexico worldwide the Caribbean community
and Mexico that mechanism sets forth an
initiative to organize an inclusive
dialogue between all political
stakeholders inside Venezuela president
Maduro has already positively mentioned
this initiative and he is ready to join
the dalek without any preconditions but
unfortunately mr. guido appointed some
kind of leader by the United States
categorically against this initiative so
that's how matters stand at this point
we have a group of countries who stand
up for starting a dialogue that group is
supported by the legitimate president of
Venezuela and then there is a different
camp camp of countries who are under
full influence of the United States they
refuse to accept that initiative there
is also an international contact group
created by the EU back last year the
European countries were considering this
it was very constructive at that point
they wanted to facilitate a dialogue
inside Venezuela but at some point later
on this position transferred into a
different field of action they said that
there is an ultimatum and there should
be early elections the European
countries and that contact group was at
the meeting in Uruguay where formulating
a document but that document does not
include anything which comes close to a
dialogue no word dialogue at all only
calling and demanding for early
presidential election of Venezuela
that's all it contains this position is
not constructive that's neocolonialism
understand that sometimes it's difficult
to drop old habits
existing for centuries but they need to
do that this structure this national
counter grow the legitimate government
of Israel is ready to talk to it
and this is a very good example as to
how constructive Midori's and his
government is and how destructive and
confront tensional the opposition is and
that man appointed leader of the state
from either the ocean from abroad and it
violates the UN Charter at international
law I'll start with your second question
the question about the relocation of the
be devious VSA office to Moscow we are
doing this in accordance with our plans
to expand our cooperation with Rosneft
and Gazprom and this is a good moment
for us to do that we are reformatting
our relations and Europe has not given
us enough guarantees because the
capitalist world is breaking its own
rules and they cannot guarantee that our
assets will be intact the Bank of
England expropriated our gold they broke
it it broke its own rules you can also
think of the what happened to Seco this
company was basically stolen from us by
the United States it was basically just
armed robbery as far as your first
question about the intervention the
situation is complicated including the
situation with
opposition in Venezuela it's not a
United Group and they don't really know
how to get support of the people how to
get more votes and that's what why
they're screaming about a military
intervention because that is the only
way for them to take power they failed
to do this
through an election that's why they now
want to use power and on February 23rd
it was an operation aimed at attack in
Venezuela mr. duco came to coo coo Kota
mr. Abrams was there too the president
of Paraguay they were all in cucuta for
this big operation against Venezuela and
why does one of Guido's comrades almost
died because he was spending the night
with prostitutes in the same city he was
poisoned by the prostitutes and he was
hospitalized so while they were paying
some criminal groups in Venezuela to
start violence in Venezuela they were
celebrating they were entertaining
themselves and I think that just goes to
show what kind of people that he
opposition in Venezuela consists of they
cannot win the votes of the people in
Venezuela so they just always ask all
the others to do their dirty work so
let's conclude their press conference
thank you for participating